okay today I'm going to talk to you
about investigating motion so we're
going to have a look at this equipment
set up and see how we can use it to
calculate the acceleration of this
little trolley right here so first of
all a quick reminder this here is the
equation for acceleration acceleration
equals the final velocity take away the
initial velocity divided by the time
between the two different places where
we were measuring velocity so we can use
this bit of equipment here or this set
up of equipment here in order to to do
this so first of all we have a trolley
this is the thing that we are going to
be measuring the acceleration of on it
we have a mass let's say to begin with
let's say we have a hundred grams mass
just on the trolley because what we're
going to do our independent variable is
going to be changing the mass that we
have on the trolley itself we then have
these things here called liked gates now
what light gates do is they measure the
velocity so as this trolley goes through
the light gate it has this little piece
of card mounted on it and as it passes
through the like light the light gate
can tell us the velocity at that point
you can also see we have masses that are
hung right here these are the things
that actually pull the trolley down as
you can see they're attached to a string
which pulls the trolley as soon as we
release this so in this experiment we
need to keep this the masses that we put
here the same because that's a control
variable we need the same angle of this
ramp and we also need the same material
of the ramp as well okay so let's just
think let's try and relate this setup of
equipment here to this equation so the
final velocity is going to be measured
here at this second light gate because
that is our final velocity my initial
velocity we are going to get that from
this first light gate here so that's
where we're going to find the value for
u it's from the first light game time
the T in this particular equation that's
the time that it takes to get between
these
two light gates so we're going to need
to time that on a stopwatch to see how
long it takes to get from there to there
some equipment it depends on your setup
can actually do that function for you
because these wires are attached to
something called a data logger and that
bit of equipment is what actually
digitally records your results so let's
just imagine that now so let's imagine
I've got all of my equipment set up I'm
holding this for now because I don't
want my trolley to move until I start
and then I let it go as these masses
move down towards the ground it's going
to drag the the trolley through it goes
through the first light go through the
second light gate these two light gates
take a reading the velocity also the
second it passes through the first one I
start the stopwatch the secondly pass
through then the other one I stop the
stopwatch so let's just imagine for this
first one let's just imagine the initial
velocity was zero point one meters per
second let's imagine the final velocity
was zero point five meters per second
and let's say the time that it took to
get through let's say it took one second
okay so let's use our equation in order
to figure out the acceleration so for a
hundred grams our acceleration equals it
equals zero point five because that's my
money for V take away my initial value
which is zero point one my initial
velocity divided by the time the time it
took was one second
so my acceleration is going to equal
well let's talk quickly about this zero
point five take away 0.1 is 0.4 superba
4/1 it's just 0.4 as well meters per
second squared so that's how I've used
this equipment here in order to find my
acceleration now let's imagine instead
of having a hundred grams because in the
first one we had a hundred grams let's
say I put on another mass here and we
have 200 grams this time round so how is
that going to change things so let's
imagine
this time my final velocity instead
let's say it's 0.3 m/s and let's say
this time it actually took two seconds
to get through rather than one so
because the more the more masses we have
the the kind of longer it's going to
take the two to get between these two
gates so with that in mind let's try and
use for 200 grams and use the equation
again to find out what the acceleration
would be this time so acceleration this
time a final velocity is actually slower
than it was before
so this time that's 0.3 meters per
second
take away my initial velocity don't say
that was still 0.1 for sake of argument
and then divide it by the time this time
the time took 2 seconds so let's figure
out the acceleration this time so 0.3
takeaway 0.1 is 0.2 0.2 divided by 2 is
0.1 m/s squared so as you can see the
more masses that I put onto my trolley
the lower the acceleration so this is
that's how these masses affect the
acceleration that is how you can
investigate motion are using these light
gates and this set of equipment thank
you